my buddy called me not too long ago and  um he was like man I gained a bunch of  weight over quarantine and I developed a  very specific problem  um will you write a song about it and I  said absolutely  here you go  well I gained a few pounds belly is big  and round  I lost my junk under my guts  thanks to the Rona I can't see my boner  I'm sorry that's so stupid  thank you  okay hold on  thanks to the Rona I can't see my boner  and my balls are somewhere near my butt  and I saw the surprise in my wife's eyes  which when she saw my pubic hair  she said you need a trim I don't know  where to begin but I'll never find Waldo  in there that's all I got right now  [Applause]  [Music]  that's how big her titties were they  made that noise through the air